yeah 23 years old 6-1 190 last start
august 13th against the braves took the
tough luck four to two loss gave up
three runs on five hits all solo home
runs in that one
one in the fifth one in the six and one
in the seventh
six strikeouts no walks
so a minute late here at 406 p.m marcus
simeon takes a big cut at the first
pitch from josiah gray this one in the
air a long time yadiel hernandez drifts
back to the wall one pitch one long out
for josiah gray two men to the left side
two on the right for beshet and a swing
and a fly ball shallow left shortstop
escobar going out calling for it and he
makes the catch
pops up on a slider on the 01 three
pitches and two outs machete just five
for his last 27. now vladimir guerrero
jr hitting it 316 second on the geico
american league leaderboard in banning
136 hits third in the league includes 20
doubles a triple 35 home runs here's the
wine now in the pitch swinging a ground
ball deep in the hole back into by
escobar long off balance throw on one
off in time to bell to get guerrero on
the side retired
one two three inning for josiah gray on
the mountain they will face
jose barrios
fourth start for the blue jays since
coming over in that big trade with the
minnesota twins
at 24 start of the year i mentioned that
last start for barrios fp that was the
only the second time
all season in his 23 starts that he
didn't go at least five innings victor
robles greets him rudely
line drive single into left field stay
hot victor robles city's escobar drove
in two last night and he is the only guy
in this nationals lineup with more than
four career at-bats against jose barrios
robles taking off this time barrios
picks it off and tries to go to second
and throws it away
robles will move up to third runners at
the corners with nobody out and an
ill-advised decision there
by jose barrios who pats himself on the
chest telling his teammates that's my
bad and so now runners first and third
and nobody out for juan soto now the set
of the pitch soto swings drops into the
air to deep left field back comes the
left fielder goriel and it is gone
goodbye
a line shot over the left fielder's head
and over the wall
for an opposite field three run home run
for juan soto
his 20th home run of the year
rbi 64 65 and 66
a laser beam hit by soto at 110 miles an
hour
386 feet of the estimated distance
and juan soto for
the nationals with home run number 20
and a three nothing lead against barrios
in the blue jays it'll be another 3-2
pitch here
to ki boom the wine by barrios here it
comes and a fastball locked him up it's
in there strike three call
he's had a terrific road trip 16 hits in
32 at bounce on the road trip with four
home runs from the line great deals and
a breaking ball is lined in the air out
to left field that is screaming towards
the wall and it's going to go
to oscar hernandez flexing for number 22
a rising line drive pulled over the wall
and left hernandez turned around to play
the bounce off the wall ante oscar
hernandez clears the vents with his 22nd
home run of the season
hernandez is homered in four straight
games
when you're locked in like he is locked
in the ball looks big and it doesn't
matter the count or the pitch and now
back to the top of the order with two
outs 2-0 there's a swing and a high fly
ball out to deep left field hernandez
stops at the wall it's out of here
marcus simeon with number 28 on the
season and all of a sudden the blue jays
are down a run they've left the yard
twice so grace goes slider slider he's
down 2-0
elevates a fastball marcus knows he's
got to throw him a fastball with two
outs and a two-run lead here's guerrero
pachette is running the pitch is swung
on and skyed to deep left center field
back in this one hernandez to the
warning track in front of the wall he
leaps and he makes the catch
up against the bullpen fence just to the
left of the 377 mark would not have left
the ballpark but a terrific leaping grab
taking an extra base hit and an rbi away
from vladimir carrero jr
and grace survives the inning with the
lead intact garcia at first here's the
pitch adams launches one to left center
toward the gap this one's going to get
down and it bounces over the wall for a
double and that's a bad break because
garcia was trucking around third and
would have scored and the ball stayed in
play
riley adams will settle for an automatic
double
that was a bullet it hit the hard
warning track and bounced into brewhouse
red seats that brings up the pitcher
josiah gray no balls two strikes the
pitch another curveball swinging a miss
gray had no shot he was stepping in the
bucket there strikeout for jose barrios
he'll leave two runners in scoring
position and bring the ball game to the
fifth to oscar teed off to open up the
second inning a rising line drive into
the blue jay bullpen that got toronto on
the board there's a drive into the alley
and that's going to get down and go past
robles all against the wall
the oscar is headed for a second and he
slides in ahead of the tag man oh man he
is red hot another extra base hit forty
oscar yeah and there's something about
the washington nationals that he really
likes may's already in the 2-2 swinging
a ground ball towards the middle of the
diamond sliding to a stop bechet's got
it in the outfield grasp from his knee
onto first in time
another fantastic defensive play for bo
bushette he was shading up the middle
and then went to a knee and throws from
his knees got a good break on it yeah he
was anticipating that ball to his right
but hernandez is able to get inside that
thing send it right back through the
middle report dickerson who came in in
the double switch will get his first
played appearance of the afternoon
swinging a long fly ball they're right
soto back at the track at the wall home
run corey dickerson waded back on that
curveball and has tied it up with a
two-run home run his second home run on
this road trip he had a game plan that
he was going to wait for that thing
let it break and it broke right where he
likes it there's marcus simeon and he
rockets one out to deep left field
turning around hernandez and that ball
is gone
it's gone
the blue jays have gone back to back in
the seventh and taken a 5-4 lead
rory dickerson didn't have to wear that
thing very long did he did he even have
a chance to put that jacket on fell in a
big spot once again not exactly
unfamiliar and is ready he deals
swinging a long drive right center field
this one's got a chance it's way back
there toward the wall and it's gone
nationals lead seven five
three run opposite field home run number
20 of the season for josh bell it clears
the big wall in right center into the
first row and the nationals treat their
former teammate quite rudely pitch to
keyboard is hit to deep left field down
the line toward the corner forget about
it it is long gone
carter keyboard home run number three on
the season nationals lead eight five and
the nats have responded big time here
off brad hand in the bottom half of the
seventh day two out top of the ninth
inning pachette off second the two old
pitch swinging a ground ball up the
middle garcia slides back hands from a
knee his throw on the money in time for
the out with a stretch by bell
and the game is over a curly w's in the
books
the nationals make it a two-game
interleague sweep of the toronto blue
jays
[Music]